multiplica y simplifica 5 raíz cúbica de
2x cuadrada por 3 3 cúbica de 4x cuarta
y aquí hay dos cosas que se me ocurren
por un lado la multiplicación es
conmutativa es decir podemos invertir el
orden los factores con lo cual las
constantes podríamos multiplicar las
primero podemos multiplicar 5 por 3
lo otro que se me ocurre es que estos
dos términos lo estamos elevando a la
raíz cúbica y elevada a la raíz cúbica
es elevar a la un tercio es decir raíz
cúbica de x es igual a x elevada a la un
tercio
hagamos eso invirtamos el orden y
describimos estas raíces cúbicas como si
estudian elevadas a la potencia un
tercio tenemos entonces el 5 y el 3 que
estamos multiplicando 5 por 3 y luego
tenemos la raíz cúbica de 2x cuadrada
déjame hacerlo con otro color mejor la
raíz cúbica de 2x cuadrada que la
podemos escribir como 2x cuadrada
elevada a la un tercio
multiplicando a la raíz cúbica de 4x
cuarta 4 x cuarta elevada a la
un tercio ahora sabemos por las
propiedades de los exponentes que si
tenemos el producto de dos cosas que
están elevadas a la misma potencia
podemos tomar primero el producto y
luego elevarlo a la potencia es decir si
tengo a elevada a la potencia x por b
elevada a la potencia x esto es lo mismo
que a por de elevado a la potencia x así
es que esta parte de aquí la podemos
reescribir como dos equis cuadrada por
4x cuarta todo es elevado a la un tercio
y por supuesto cinco por tres es igual a
15 y ahora esta expresión de aquí es un
producto es conmutativo ya hemos
mencionado eso y también es asociativo
no importa el orden en el que hacemos
las operaciones entonces esto de aquí lo
puedo simplificar como dos por cuatro
esto es igual a seis y equis cuadrada
por equis cuarta esto es igual a equis a
la sexta y todo eso elevado a la un
tercio y esto x
pero el perdón aquí tengo un error
discúlpame 2 x 4 no es 62 por 4 es 8 y
luego x cuadrada por x cuarta es x a la
sexta x a la sexta si creo que estaba
sumando estos exponentes por eso decía
que 2 x 4 era 6 pero no es 8 y aquí al
sumar estos exponentes para dar x a la
sexta mi cerebro no funcionó bien ahí
así es que esto es 8 x sexta elevado a
la un tercio
y todo esto multiplicado por 15 que
ahora podemos usar esta misma propiedad
bueno no exactamente esta misma
propiedad no si si si si esta misma
propiedad pero el sentido inverso la
usamos de la siguiente manera 8 x x a la
sexta elevado a la un tercio es igual a
8 elevado a un tercio por x a la sexta
elevado a la un tercio y todo esto
multiplicado
todo esto multiplicado por 15 ahora 8 al
un tercio es lo mismo que raíz cúbica de
8 y como 8 es igual a 2 x
2 x 2 es decir 2 al cubo la raíz cúbica
de 2 al cubo es 2 al exponente 1
simplemente dos y x a la sexta elevada
al un tercio
bueno aplicando las propias de los
exponentes este lo mismo que x elevado a
las seis por un tercio seis por un
tercio es 2
así es que esto de aquí es equivalente a
x cuadrada
que tenemos entonces 15 por 2 15 por 2
es 30
este término aquí es 30 lo cual
multiplica a déjame hacerlo con otro
color multiplica a no es en este otro
color que multiplica a x cuadrada hemos
terminado hay varias maneras en que
podías haber hecho esto podrías no haber
usado la anotación de exponentes aquí
podrías decir bueno aquí tengo la raíz
cúbica de esto la raíz cúbica de esto
como la raíz cúbica del producto y
entonces en vez de este exponente tengo
aquí una raíz cúbica y dependiendo de
cómo lo agrupe podría hacer esto en
distinto orden mientras sus en las
propiedades adecuadas de los exponentes
deberás de llegar aquí deberás de
obtener esta misma respuesta